Hello everyone.
And uh welcome to lecture three of CEE
296.
So today is a very special day because
we're going to talk about flow matching
which is a generation paradigm that is
quite trendy these days.
So if you remember
lectures one and lecture two
were also about generation paradigm
where we talked about diffusion with
DDPM in lecture one
and score matching in lecture two.
So flow matching is yet another
generation paradigm
and we're going to see in this lecture
what is the mindset behind that separate
paradigm and how it relates to diffusion
and score matching.
So as usual we're going to start the
class with a recap of the last episodes.
So if you remember
lecture one
we saw how we could generate new samples
and the way we thought about doing that
was taking images from our training set
which we named clean images
and what we did is that we gradually
corrupted them with a process that we
defined
a process Q.
Which
given an image at a given time step
noises by adding some Gaussian noise
weighted by some coefficient.
And the goal of diffusion with DDPM was
to find or was to learn a reverse
process which we noted P theta
that removed the noise gradually.
And what we saw was that in order to
learn P theta,
what we did is
try to maximize the likelihood of our
model seeing
the training data.
And if you remember, we did some clever
math with
um some estimation of the lower bound so
the elbow and we derived some terms and
we ended up with a pretty good-looking
loss,
which was which was the just an L2
regression on the noise that was added
up to the image at time step t.
And so,
this was lecture one.
Lecture two was taking another
perspective
and just taking a step back,
thinking of images in the space of the n
n-dimensional space of images.
And the fact that what we wanted to do
was sample from an easy distribution
and then
walk our way up until the true data
distribution.
So, how did you do that?
The whole point of the lecture
was to learn what we call the score,
which is the gradient of the log of P.
And why did we do that? Because it acted
as a sort of a compass from where we
were up until regions of high density.
And
if we learn such a score, what we could
do was use sampling techniques such as
Langevin sampling,
which allowed us to move towards
high-density regions, but also allow for
some diversity with some noise term.
And we saw that in order for us to
estimate that score,
we cleverly noised the initial data
distribution
in order to learn the score of the
noised distribution.
And then we had
a progressive
noise schedule that allowed us to
progressively work our way up until the
data distribution. So, we ended up with
a score function
that was a function of
the position in space, but also the
noise level.
And again, after doing some clever math,
we also ended up with an L2 regression
loss,
which was quite easy to compute.
But, what we also saw was that what we
saw in lecture two was actually quite
related to what we saw in lecture one,
because both
involved adding noise.
And in particular, we saw that there was
a relationship between the score of
a noisy distribution and the noise that
we added from the clean image
to the noisy image.
So, given that,
what we did was
think of a unified way of looking at
both these perspectives,
and we moved from a discrete
representation to a continuous one.
And we obtained this ST, which was of
the form DX equal f of x and t dt plus
dt times dw, where w is our winner
process, which is introducing the
stochasticity.
And in particular, the first term is
called the drift term, and it is a term
that quantifies the deterministic
movement in space
across time.
And the second term is called the
diffusion term,
which quantifies the amount
of stochasticity that you have in in
your process.
So, this expression is the expression of
the forward pass, meaning you're
actually noising your images.
And we saw that in space, if we were to
represent that, it meant again having a
drift component and a diffusion
component.
So, now if we wanted to denoise our
image,
we're actually interested in the reverse
process,
which we saw thanks to
uh SD result from the '80s, involved
knowing the score.
So, this expression is the reverse
process that allows us to denoise
images, which is why we need to learn
the score.
And this is where the score comes in
in the continuous view.
So, this was 2 weeks ago and a week ago.
But today,
we're going to see this third
generation paradigm, which is called
flow matching.
And similar to the past lectures, what
we're going to try to do is to have a
nice balance between intuition
and math.
Cuz you will see that these papers are
full of math, full of equations, and we
will try to approach it from an
intuitive perspective, but not shy away
from the math either.
And of course, please interrupt me at
any point if you if you feel there's
something that's uh not clear.
Cool?
Okay. Let's start.
So,
the whole point of these first three
lectures is to find a way to go from
somewhere that is easy to sample from
up until
our data distribution of interest.
So, the way that flow matching works is
it has two distributions.
The first one is called the initial
distribution, which is the distribution
that you're you're starting from.
And then the second distribution is
called the target distribution.
And it is the distribution that you want
to end up with.
And the whole point of flow matching
is finding a way
to transport
our initial data distribution
up until the target distribution.
And just note the terminology I'm using.
Transport.
So, what we want
is to transport the whole density that
we have. And remember that
probability densities have these very
nice property of summing to one. So, we
want to transport the whole
density distribution from one place
to another.
So, this is the idea behind flow
matching. And we're going to see how we
we can do that.
So,
I'm going to just give you a warning in
terms of conventions.
In the past, we've seen that zero was
clean data, and then capital T was the
noise data, but here it's going to be
different.
So, we will be noting P zero
our initial data distribution, which is
typically something that is easy to
sample from, such as Gaussian noise
and
the target data distribution is going to
be noted P1.
T equal 1 and this is where we want to
end up with.
And then again, so this slide is just to
say that
lectures 1 and 2 we said 0 was clean,
capital T was noise.
But here 0 will be noise
and 1
will be what we want which is the clean
images
which is the data distribution.
So the reason why we chose to proceed
that way is just that the fields
chose these conventions and if we were
to keep the conventions
of the diffusion and score matching
fields, it would just
completely confuse you if you were to
read papers from the flow matching field
which is the reason why we're keeping
things consistent with the paper.
But just keep those things in mind
because sometimes these conventions can
also be reversed depending on which
paper you're reading but this one is by
far the most common.
Cool. So with that warning aside
what we want to do is to sample
an observation from our initial data
distribution
and then map it to the target data
distribution.
So in order to do that
we're now going to go through some
common notations
and the first one is called the
trajectory.
So the trajectory is noted XT
and it is the path that is taken by an
observation between times 0 and 1.
So by the way, the time 0 and 1 is
arbitrary. It's just a way for us to
say, "Okay, when are we starting and
when are we ending?"
And so, here at time t = 0, we have x0,
and what we want to do is for our
trajectory to map
a point from p0
up until
p1.
So, that's our goal.
So, now
let's see another notation. So, this one
is called the flow.
The flow is noted as psi
of t of x0.
So, I'm just going to write that down
here.
So, it is a function
that takes
time
and
an initial condition
and it gives you
where that point is
at time t.
So, this is the time, so
belongs to 0 1. This one is to your
space, which is
maybe um I don't know, d-dimensional.
And this one is also
in the d-dimensional space.
And you have psi of t of x0, which is
equal to
your point at time t, which is x of t.
So,
the flow you can interpret it in
different ways.
So, one way you can interpret it is it's
a collection of trajectories.
Because if you change the initial
condition x0,
then psi t of x0 is all the possible
trajectories that go from an initial
condition x0
up until
time t.
>> [snorts]
>> Yeah?
Um
the flow can also be seen as a function
that maps
your initial condition to where it
should be
at time t.
And this is why it's called the flow.
So this function is quite
important because at the end of the day
what you want is psi one
of x0
to be this to be sampled from to be as
if it was sampled from p1, which is your
target data distribution.
Cool. So now we have our next
terminology, which is called the
probability path.
And it's denoted pt of x.
So pt of x
is the probability distribution
of your observations at time t.
So p0 of of x is your initial data
distribution.
And p1 of x is your
target data distribution.
So if t is between zero and one
is basically the
intermediary
probability
data distribution.
And as you can imagine
in order to go from p0 to p1
you have an infinite number
of ways of going from one to the other.
So pt is by no means unique.
There are many ways for for you to go
from zero to one.
Cool. And now we're going to talk about
a central
object of this whole field.
And it's called the vector field.
So vector field is noted ut of x.
And it is a function that takes in
a place in space so X
and a time T.
And it gives you a vector.
And that vector
you can interpret it as the direction
and the speed
that particles should move at that
location at at that time.
So again, the vector field takes in a a
vector which is your position in space
and gives you also a vector
which is where you need to move and
and how fast.
And we're going to see that
the vector field is quite central to
flow matching.
But before we do that
I know last lecture we talked about the
score
and the score was
also a vector.
And if you remember the score was also
something we used in order to go from
noise
to data.
So one natural question you may be
asking yourself right now is well, how
does this vector field or velocity
relates
to the score?
So I'm going to give you the following
analogy.
So let's suppose you want to go from
your initial distribution to your target
distribution
and let's suppose that you're thinking
of this in terms of
self-driving cars
that are distributed let's say in a
Gaussian fashion in the middle of the
desert.
And what you want to do is to position
your
self-driving cars
in a certain way
so that it follows let's say a target
data distribution.
So the way you would think of
the velocity would be
instructions that you would give to your
self-driving cars
at a given location
and at a given time t.
So, if the vec- vector field was not
time dependent, you could even think of
it as highways, you know, routes with
speed limits.
But here, the vector field is actually
time dependent, which means that at at a
given location x
and at two different time steps, t1 and
t2,
that vector can actually be different.
And in that sense,
just following with that self-driving
car example,
the score would be
a bit like a compass that you could see
in your car
of where
high-density regions are.
>> [snorts]
>> So, I hope this is useful to just
picture the difference between what a
velocity is and what
a score is. So, these two are vectors,
but they have different interpretations.
Any questions so far?
Yeah, we've barely started, uh so we're
going to see um few things here, but I
just want to make sure that the
notations so far are clear.
Yeah, all good?
Cool. So, we're going to see our first
identity here.
So, we introduced the vector field, aka
the velocity,
because this is the
way we're going to
have our particles move from one place
to another.
And in particular,
the definition we're giving to the
velocity, aka the vector field, is given
as follows.
So, what we're going to say is that a
change in position
will be associated with the velocity at
that location at at that time t
times dt.
So, in other words
a given particle in a given location
will be moving
according to that velocity.
And one thing that I want to tell you
is that the trajectory, which as a
reminder is a whole path that the
particle is taking from time t equal
zero to time t equal to one.
That trajectory is actually going to be
unique for a given
initial condition.
If there's a special condition on the
vector field, which is that if the
vector field is Lipschitz continuous.
So, the reason why I'm bringing this up
is because it's going to be important.
And so, who knows what Lipschitz
continuity is? Have you ever heard of
this term?
Yeah?
No? Okay. So, maybe I can just recap the
mathematical definition and maybe how it
means what it means.
So, Lipschitz continuity of a function f
>> [snorts]
>> is
when you have some constant, let's call
it m,
such that for all x and y
in your
space of interest, you have
your function
f that satisfies
this relationship. So, the norm of f of
x minus f of y is less or equal than m
times the norm of x
minus y.
So, what this means is that
f needs to be continuous,
but also not vary in a very dramatic
way.
So, this is the mathematical definition
of Lipschitz continuity, and what I'm
saying here is if the vector field
is Lipschitz continuous,
then the trajectories
x
will be unique
for a given initial condition.
And so, I'm going to just give you an
example of
of when trajectories are not unique.
So,
so here we have
our ODE,
which is here,
like so.
I'm just going to give you an example of
if we have a vector field that is not
Lipschitz continuous, how we can have
trajectories that start from the same
points, but they're actually different.
So, here the example is as follows. So,
let's suppose we have
uh your vector field, which
is given by this,
by let's say square root of x, and you
only consider, by the way, x
positive or zero.
So, if your vector field, by the way, is
time independent and it's just a
function of of x via
square root of x,
then
if you say
you want your initial condition to be x
zero is equal to zero,
then
x t
equal to zero
is going to be a solution.
But
x t equals to
t squared
over four
is also going to be a solution.
So here t squared over four so like the
derivative is t over two.
And here's when you
put this also in the square root, it's
also
t over two.
So all of that to say that
your vector field needs to have needs to
behave
in a certain way if you want to
guarantee that your trajectories are are
unique.
And this is Lipschitz continuity.
And you're going to see why that
matters.
Cool. So that's the first equation
that's going to be important. So the ODE
here, which is
d dx over dt is equal to the velocity at
location x and time t. It's the first
one.
The second one that we're going to see
is the following.
So I told you
that what we want to do
is transport our distribution
from one place to another.
So when you transport something
one thing that you want to guarantee
is that you're not going to lose or gain
anything of what you're transporting.
You have what we call conservation of
mass.
And this idea is also something we want
to put in writing.
And in particular
we're going to focus on the following
case.
So let's assume you're in a region of
space and you consider a very small
area.
And here you have your data distribution
that is, you know, around it.
So, the equation that we want to put in
writing
is
around making sure that
the evolution
of your density
at time t
is equal to
the density that is coming
minus the density that is
going out
or that is leaving.
Do you all agree with this idea?
So, the evolution of density as at time
t
is a function of how much density comes
in
minus how many comes out.
So,
the left-hand side is kind of easy.
It's just a partial derivative of
your probability path at that region
with respect to time.
But, then the right side
I don't know about you, but very
intuitively there's not like
a supernatural operator that that does
that.
So, what we're going to see now is
how we can quantify the idea on the
right side of the equal sign.
But, before we do that, just want to
take a pause. Does this idea make sense?
Conservation of mass.
By the way, have you seen it in another
topic?
Yeah?
So, in physics you have the same thing.
And it's actually called it has a name.
It's called the continuity equation.
Anyways, so
instead of just giving you the formula,
we're just going to intuitively
intuitively get to it.
And in particular, I want us to think
about this right-hand side
of this equation
and think for a bit how we want to
quantify the inflow minus outflow bit.
So, let's suppose
you have an operator that's called the
divergence.
But right now
I'm not telling you anything about what
that operator is. I'm just telling you
that the operator is positive
when things are
coming out more than they're coming in.
And we're going to see what happens
then.
So, here
when we're talking about coming in and
coming out, we're of course talking
about vectors.
So, here we're assuming
for instance, if there's more coming out
than coming in, that
let's assume if we are in one
dimensional space
you have
a vector
that is such that
at first it's small in magnitude
and then it's much bigger in magnitude.
So, here do you agree with me that
whatever this vector is representing,
there is more coming out than coming in.
You all agree?
Okay, so that's one
one case where coming out can be more
than coming in. So, let's let's see a
second case. So, the second case is
here and then let's say your vector is
coming out here and coming coming out
there.
Yeah?
I'm sure you can have more cases than
that, but
in this one D example
if you were to represent
your vector, let's say F
over the dimension X,
here
what is the magnitude of F doing?
It is increasing.
Okay, so here
we just see that
partial derivative of X over X is
increasing. How about here? So, here
it's negative and then it becomes
positive.
Also increasing, right?
Okay, so based on this
very back of the envelope
intuition,
we see that
when things are leaving,
partial derivative of X over this
dimension of F over this dimension X is
positive,
which seems to match
the sign that we want from our
divergence operation.
So, now let's see the other case. So,
let's assume that we have now the case
where we want our operator
to be negative when there is
more coming than leaving.
So, here again
this example, so you have, let's say,
bigger vector here coming and then um
smaller one leaving.
And then, let's say you have another
case, which is given by this,
which is just
vectors pointing towards that area.
So, here you see that
F
is becoming more and more negative when
you project it on X.
So, here you have
partial derivative of F over X,
which is negative. And here you see that
it was first positive and then it
becomes negative.
Which again
boils down to this.
So this is by no means
a formal proof.
But I hope
I gave you some intuition that if you
take
the partial derivative of
your function that is outputting a
vector over its coordinates
at least in 1D
it would give you
this intuition that if it's positive
then it's more coming out and when it's
negative then there's more coming in.
So based on this intuition
what I'm now telling you is that there
is an operator
that is indeed called the divergence
that is a function of
a vector that is a function of
X which is also multi-dimensional
and
what it is doing
is
it is just a sum of the partial
derivatives of X over each dimension.
So the divergence is a scalar.
It's a number.
And if it's positive it just means that
there are more things coming out and if
it's negative it means there are more
things coming in.
So based on that
we want to see how we can use this
divergence operator
back into our continuity equation
example where we want to
quantify the fact that
we want the net inflows which is
how much density is coming
in versus out.
So now a second question
is something that we ask ourselves,
which is okay, what what should we use
as F?
What should F be?
So, we saw the vector field, which is a
vector that could be a candidate.
So, do you think the vector field could
be a good candidate?
So, let's see with an example. So, let's
suppose you have two points in space,
let's say X1 and X2, and then you have
their respective vector fields.
If you happen to have a higher density
in one of the two points,
then our intuition tells us that you
would want the points in the higher
density region to transport more things
than the one in the lower den- density
region.
So, in that case, the vector field alone
would actually not be a good candidate.
Instead, maybe you have guessed it,
in order to quantify the movement of
density,
we of course need to take into
consideration the probability density.
And so, here the actual quantity that we
use is called the probability flux.
And it is defined by
P T, which is a scalar,
times U T,
which is the vector field.
So,
going back to the equation that we
wanted to put in writing,
what we're saying is that the temporal
evolution of the density at time T,
which we said
is simply the partial derivative of P
with respect to T,
we're now saying that this is equal
to minus the divergence
of the probability flux.
And this quantity, so minus divergence
of PTUT of X,
it just means
that we're interested in the net inflows
of density within our small volume.
So, all in all,
that equation, which I'm going to write,
is nothing else than the continuity
equation,
which you may have seen in physics.
So,
I'm going to write it down. Of course,
okay, this is here.
So, what we're saying is that the
evolution of density
at a given location,
the temporal evolution of the density at
a given location is given by how much
density is coming in minus how much
density is coming out.
And this
just conveys the fact
that we're not creating new density out
of thin air. We're just conserving it
when time goes from T 0 to T 1.
And
compared to the OD that we saw before,
you can think of this equation as being
a macro perspective of how your
probability path evolves.
And the OD
itself is actually centered on how one
particle evolves, which is more a micro
perspective.
Which we're going to see here. So, a
single sample,
you take your sample X at time T, and
what you're saying is
that
how fast that particle is going is
actually given by the vector field at
that location at that time.
So,
the distance
DX is given by UT of X time DT.
So, this is the micro perspective.
But, where we also saw that this vector
field that was coming into the picture
in this micro perspective is also in the
macro perspective.
And what we're saying is
given that we're transporting the
density and we're not losing it or
gaining it,
we also have this nice identity that we
can use,
which is also called the continuity
equation.
And so, there is one expression that you
will see a lot in papers.
I'm going to read it out loud.
The vector field UT of X generates the
probability path.
So, when people say that, what they mean
is that UT and PT
satisfy
the continuity equation.
So, now you may wonder, well,
why should we care?
So, just remember that our goal
is to sample an observation from the
initial distribution P0
and to map it
to the target data distribution.
And the way we want to map it is we want
that particle
to go from one place to another using
the vector field.
And so, what we want
is to find a probability path
that will allow us to go from P0 to P1.
And
in order to find a probability path, we
also need to find the associated vector
field
that will allow us to actually do the
mapping because that vector field
is
in the single sample perspective.
So, that's the idea. We're going to see
it in other words in a little bit, but
this is the intuition behind
flow models.
Okay. Any questions on this?
Everything is clear so clear so far?
Yep.
So, question is the solution of this
equation would be the target. So, on the
left-hand side
if
if we know UT
and if we know that UT is allowing
PT to go from P0, something that we
decide that is easy to sample, to P1
what we care about
what we're saying is if we know such a
UT
then
on the left-hand side
if you sample X from P0
you have your initial condition.
And if you know UT
what that means is you can solve this
equation
in order to find X1.
And X1 by definition will be
as if it was sampled from P1.
So, that's the idea.
I know it was a lot. I know it may not
seem clear, but don't worry. We have a
lot of examples down the line.
So, let's move on. This exactly
my next slide actually. So, here what
we're saying is
the relationship between these two
perspectives, I'm going to just repeat
what I said but in mathematical term is
if we sample
X0 from P0
given that
our particle X
is subject to velocity
then what that means is
if that velocity is actually generating
the probability path
from the initial to the target one
then what that means is that XT
will be sampled from PT.
And in particular T equal 1, X1 will be
sampled from P1.
Okay, cool. So, don't worry. We're going
to go into more details on this.
So,
the whole goal of flow models is to map
points.
It's to map X0
to X1.
So, what is our strategy here? We saw
that vector field was a central piece of
this whole problem.
So,
number one the step number one is for us
to estimate
this vector field
via some model that we're going to note
UT theta of X.
So, theta is the parameters that we're
learning.
So, if we learn such a vector field
then what we're going to do in order to
map X0 to X1
is
we're going to use the OD
and solve it numerically.
So, what does that mean?
That means that we're going to sample X0
and we're going to just going to follow
the vector field up until time [music]
equal to one.
So, this integral here in practice is
going to be just numerical solver that
maybe you know like Euler for instance.
And it's going to be giving you X1.
Which is what you want because at the
end of the day you want to be able to
sample from your target data
distribution.
So, starting from now
our full focus
will be around
finding the vector field UT theta of X.
Cuz right now I just told you what we
care about but I didn't tell you how
we're going to do that.
So, now we're going to focus on that.
So,
in the past there's been many papers
published on this on how you can
estimate
your vector field.
And there is one method that I'm going
to
mention here which is not going to be
the focus of this class because
it is a method that was used
a number of years ago so eight years ago
I believe.
But
it is not something that could be used
in practice so people are not using it
so far but I'm just telling you just for
historical purposes.
So,
one way of learning the vector fields
is by maximizing the likelihood
that your model is seeing
the data, right? The training set.
So, how can you do that? Well,
if you take the continuity equation that
we saw, so this one.
So, if you take this equation
then what happens is
if you do some math
you can actually pop up that log of PT
of X, which is
what you want to maximize.
And
you can have the following strategy. So,
you want to determine log
of P1 of X1. So, X1 is your
the data from the training set. So, you
want to compute
the probability of your model seeing X1.
The The problem is you you don't know
how to compute it.
So, the way you're going to do this is
you're first going to realize that you
can compute the probability
that the
initial distribution is seeing X0
because typically the initial
distribution is a is an easy one,
something that you can analytically
compute, such as a Gaussian. So, you
know how to compute
log P0 of X0.
And what you're going to do is you're
going to link X1 and X0
by integrating
the divergence of the vector fields
because you have
the formula above that is true.
So, if you know log P0 of X0 and if you
know the vector fields,
then you can compute this quantity.
And so, what that paper was doing, which
is called continuous normalizing flow,
was that it was trying to learn the
parameters theta
by maximizing the likelihoods
of
your training sets
happening under theta.
And it was hap- it was computing the
likelihood using this formula.
So, what is the problem?
The problem is that at training time,
you need to constantly solve, you know,
this integral. So, it's a numer-
numerical solver that that works all the
time.
So, it's very expensive and very slow.
Which is why we have a a snail emoji.
So, it's just not practical. People just
couldn't couldn't use that.
And for that reason,
I hope
I did a good job of motivating the
reason why we needed another approach.
The approach we're going to see now
is actually what is called flow
matching.
Because
we're going to see we're not doing
maximum likelihood estimation, we're
instead
trying to directly learn
the vector field.
So, if you remember for score matching,
you were directly trying to learn the
score.
So, here we're directly trying to learn
the vector field, but the problem is
that you don't know what it is.
So, we're going to see
how we can
compute this loss
and indeed
optimize on theta in order to find our
vector field.
So,
just remember that
the problem that we have is we have an
initial data distribution and a target
data distribution.
And what we care about
is finding this UT of X,
which will allow us to go from P0 to P1.
That is our goal.
Well,
P0 is easy, so it's a Gaussian
typically,
but then P1 can be super complicated.
So, one idea we can have
is what if we just remembered that the
target data distribution is just
composed of
points from your training data, so it's
like individual points.
So, what if instead
we simplify our problem
and we ask ourselves
how we can transport the initial data
distribution
not to the target one
but to a single point.
How about if we just
move our whole data distribution from
initial to a single point? And here, I
noted the single point
with the distribution delta x1.
So, delta x1 is the notation for a Dirac
delta distribution. So, who has heard of
the Dirac distribution?
Yeah?
So, Dirac distribution is actually
probably the simplest distribution out
there because it's a deterministic
distribution.
It will always give you one quantity.
So, here
delta
So, I'm going to write it down.
So, delta
x1 of x
is going to be zero if
if x is different than x1.
And otherwise, it will be actually a
very high number. So, typically people
say
let's say infinity.
But of course, it's infinity but the
integral of this distribution, like the
density needs to be one.
So, long story short
is that we simplified our problem
from
initial data distribution to your target
one.
So, we we changed from that formulation
to
initial data distribution to a single
point.
So, one idea
could be for us
to think of
the following way of going from one to
the other. So, let's suppose
you have a probability path
that is super simple. It's just
a Gaussian distribution
that is being interpolated
between
zero
and X1.
So, here what I'm saying is
we How about we think of
the way we want to go from zero to the
point
by
taking our normal distribution of mean
zero and
variance identity. And how about we just
scale it down, scale it down, and then
move it towards X1
until it becomes just that point.
So, here
PT, so we say X given X1 because it's a
conditional probability path. It's like
given
we're arriving at X1 at time T equal 1.
It will be given by a mean of TX1
and a variance of 1 - T squared times
identity.
So, let me tell you why that is the
case.
So, what I'm saying here is
that I'm proposing
a way for us
to go from
the normal distribution
that is this one of mean zero
and then variance the identity. So, what
I'm saying is in order to go from here
to this point
which is X1.
What I'm telling you is we're going to
have a path
PT
given X1
which is a normal distribution of
as a function of T
cuz it's probability path at time T.
TX1
and 1 - T squared I. So, when T equals 0
this
is 0.
This is is identity.
So, P0 is
just the normal distribution of 0 and I.
And P1 is
well
T equal 1 is like just X1.
And this one is
a variance of 0, so you can think of T
just tending to 0.
So, P1 is just a Dirac distribution.
So
this probability path that I'm telling
you is something that is
letting us go from
our initial data distribution to this
point, so it's a it's a valid one.
So, why am I choosing this?
Well, it can be shown
that
one vector field that is generating this
probability path
has the following expression, so
UT of X given X1 is X1 - X over 1 - T.
So, I'm just giving you the formula, so
you can derive it.
So, I'm looking at the time, we will not
have time.
But, the reason why I proposed the
probability path
the conditional probability path is
because
it's much easier for us
to compute a vector field and it's
something that we can actually write.
And it is this one. And what I'm going
to tell you is
that this vector field
is generating the conditional
probability path.
So, in other words, the vector field
will be such that if you sample from P0
of this conditional probability path,
and if you follow this conditional
vector field,
what I am telling you is that you will
end up at time equal T
with XT
following your conditional probability
path.
Well, that's a huge step forward, no?
So, how do you prove that, by the way?
So, you just
use the quantities,
you use the vector field that is just
this formula, and you use the
conditional probability path, which you
can analytically derive because
if you remember the Gaussian
distribution, we
we just know everything about it. We
also know the density
uh formula.
So, if you take
both formula,
and if you
if you use the continuity equation,
which is here,
you can show that
this expression is true.
And this is how you prove that. Now,
we're not going to do it because this is
just some math.
But, maybe one thing I will tell you is
why
why that vector field makes sense.
So, we said that
uh plot. Okay, we said that the
conditional vector field, which is noted
UT of X given X1, what we said was that
this was equal to X1 minus X
over 1 minus T.
Well, when T
is approaching 1.
And when your X is not
near X1.
Then what you're seeing is that this
quantity goes crazy. Goes very like
close to infinity. Like it goes very
very high.
Well, why does that make sense?
It's because at time T equal 1
your distribution is literally a
deterministic distribution that is X1.
So you want all your particles to be
exactly at X1.
So if you're not at X1
then
you better hurry.
Your velocity will be very very high.
So that's one thing I want to say.
And one other thing I want to say
is there is a very nice expression of of
the conditional
vector fields.
If
XT
is drawn from that
conditional probability path, which as a
reminder is
a normal distribution of mean TX1 and 1
minus T squared I.
So if XT is drawn from such a
conditional probability path
that means that you can express XT
as follows. So TX1 plus 1 minus T X0
with
X0 drawn from
a normal distribution.
So what that means
is UT
of XT
given X1
if I were to just replace XT
in this formula.
What I would obtain is X1 minus So, XT
I'm just going to directly replace
just because I don't have space. So, T
X1 plus
1 minus T X0
over
1 minus T.
So,
X1 minus T X1 is 1 minus T times X1.
minus
1 minus T times X0
over 1 minus T. So, what that means is
this
is equal to X1 minus
X0.
The conditional vector field
for XT, which is drawn from a
conditional probability path,
is nothing else
than X1 minus X0.
Which is very nice.
So, why is it very nice?
Well, it's tractable.
And it's going to be useful for us.
Okay.
Any questions?
Yeah.
So, the question is how do we get to
that equation?
So, the question is where does this
equation comes from? So, this one, the
one above, is just an equation that I'm
just telling I'm just giving you.
And you can verify that it actually is
generating the conditional probability
because you can prove it, but we're not
just not doing it.
So, given that,
this part
is just me telling you
that this expression
can be even further simplified
if the X that you're putting here
is actually drawn
from the conditional probability path.
So, as a reminder, the conditional
probability path is given by a normal
distribution
of mean TX1
and 1 - T squared I.
So, if you were to draw from such a
distribution,
it would be the same thing
because you know X1,
it would be the same thing as
sampling from just a standard normal
Gaussian
and writing
XT as follows. Because this is your
variance, this is the mean.
So, this is the mean plus the variance
times
something that is drawn from the normal
distribution.
And so, what I'm telling you is if you
were to plug in that expression
in here,
then a lot of simplifications occur
and you end up
with a very simple expression of
the conditional vector field at that
point being equal to just X1 - X0, where
X0 is
is basically this component of XT.
And follow-up question is, well, why are
you telling me this? It's a very fair
question. I'm going to tell you in a in
uh 15 minutes.
But, does everyone agree with me so far?
I'm going to take that as a yes.
Okay.
So, now that we
looked at a very simple case of
transporting our data distribution from
this initial one to a single point.
Now, our goal is going to figure out how
we can map that back to our initial
problem.
So, our initial problem is to map from
the initial data distribution to the
target data distribution.
So,
an idea to obtain
the target data distribution
is to replicate
this conditional path
over all points
of your target data distribution.
So, if we do that, we consider, let's
say, one point
of your target data distribution, we
have this conditional probability path.
We consider a second point.
And let's assume here that our target
data distribution that our training set
only has two points.
Then, what that means is
that at time t
we can consider what we call a marginal
probability path. So, marginal because
we marginalize across the x's.
And we will end up with a mixture of
Gaussians,
where each Gaussian is interpolating
between the normal one to
the single point.
So,
let me tell you why I'm telling you all
of this.
So,
just remember that what we care about
is to map
our initial distribution to the target
one.
So, there are many ways to go from one
to the other.
And what we say is that
we can
just propose
this marginal probability path, which
I'm going to explain in a second.
So, what I'm telling you is
let's fix X1.
And just consider the conditional
probability path. So, PT of X given X1,
which is what we saw right before.
Now, let's consider all such conditional
probability path across all the X1s
that are composing our target data
distribution.
And let's consider the following
expression.
Which is a natural way of
of a defining it.
So, we notice
that P0 of X
So, P0 of X given X1 is just the the
standard normal distribution, so P0.
So, this
is indeed
the initial data distribution, so N
so, the standard Gaussian.
And
P1, what is P1?
So, we said that when T equals 1
PT of X given X1
is the Dirac.
So, this
So, when T equal 1, this one is equal to
Dirac
of X1 at X.
So, this whole thing
simplifies to
Pdata of X.
So,
this marginal probability path
is verifying P0
like T equals 0 is equal to your initial
data distribution and p1 is your target
data distribution.
So it is a valid path to go from zero to
one.
So
now our goal, because just remember what
we want is to go from zero to one
and we want to learn the vector field
that is getting us from zero to one.
So the good thing here is we have a
probability path that is getting us from
zero to one.
So now let's look at the vector field.
Let's see if there is a way for us
to aggregate the conditional vector
fields
such that it is
going to enable us to go from
zero to one.
So here we consider the conditional
vector field for each data point like
conditional each data point, so this one
and this one
and what we want is to also have a
marginal vector field.
Something that's is able to generate the
marginal probability path.
And what I'm going to tell you
is
that
the way we want to aggregate the vector
field
is going to actually be quite intuitive.
So I'm going to just write write it
down.
So up until now what we're doing is
we're
constructing things.
We're constructing things and then we're
verifying that it's actually something
that is
what we want. So what I'm saying is
we're going to aggregate the conditional
vector fields
by considering the following
aggregation. So I'm going to take my
conditional vector fields and I'm going
to aggregate it as follows. So I'm going
to say it's equal
to this.
So pt So, the conditional probability
path uh times P data of X1
over the marginal probability path,
which we have derived
a short while ago. And I'm going to say
that this is my definition. This is my
proposed definition of the marginal
vector field.
So, this expression
may seem scary to you.
But, if you remember Bayes' rule,
this one
you recognize Bayes' rule here, right?
Like a little bit.
So, it's as if So, I'm going to put this
in quotes.
So, it's as if it was
the probability of
X1 being where you're headed
given X, which is where you are.
So, the way you're aggregating your
conditional vector fields is
Okay, I'm at point X.
And
I'm going to weight
each conditional vector fields
with a weight
that is telling me the probability of
this X1 being my destination
given where I am.
So, this is So, you can think of this as
the posterior mean.
And this coefficient can be interpreted
as Okay, given where I am,
how likely is it that this point is
where I want to go?
And now,
I'm going to tell you
the biggest result.
This marginal vector field, which we
defined,
is actually generating the probability
path, the marginal probability path.
So, this is a big deal. So, what that
means is there is a vector field
that is generating the probability path
that is actually something that
satisfies
what we want, which is it's a path that
goes from
the initial to the target.
So, I'm looking at the time. Um
I'm not going to derive it, but I'm
going to derive something else instead.
So,
in order for you to show that this
vector field is generating the
probability path
is by just plugging these quantities
in the continuity equation. So, I'm not
going to do it. I'm just going to tell
you
how you would do it.
So, we just do that. So, you take your
marginal probability paths, you derive
it here, and just just recognize that it
is indeed the minus the divergence of
the marginal probability path and the
marginal vector field.
So, what this is telling us
is
if we sample X0 from P0, which is the
initial one,
then
if we follow
the marginal vector field,
then XT is going to be following
the probability path P(t).
This is huge because if you take X0
and you take it all the way to t equal 1
with the vector fields,
then X1 will be actually following P1,
which is what you care about.
So, this is huge.
This can be proven mathematically. We're
not going to do it with respect
to how much time we have.
And so, this leads us
to our initial problem.
Which is us
wanting to learn
a vector field that will allow us to go
from P0 to P1.
So here, what I'm going to tell you is
that optimizing
for the flow matching loss that I told
you at the very beginning
is equivalent to you optimizing for what
we call the conditional flow matching
loss,
which is given by here.
And I'm going to
tell you more about this
for the next 5 minutes.
So let me take this.
So
here what we want is to have a tractable
loss.
And if you look at
the flow matching loss,
it is still a loss that is quite
complex.
So our goal is to really make our loss
as tractable as possible.
So as a result, what we're saying is
that the loss of flow matching
which is given by this, so it's the
expectation of the square distance of
your learned
vector field minus the marginal vector
field that you constructed.
So what we're saying is
optimizing for the loss above
is the same as optimizing for the
conditional
flow matching loss,
which is this one.
So, if we aggregate [snorts]
over time steps T
and X
drawn from the probability path PT
of this expression, what I'm saying is
that optimizing for this loss is the
same as optimizing for the
conditional flow matching loss,
where the expectation is over T,
X1,
and then X
belonging to
the conditional probability path.
And back to your question,
this whole expression that we had here
was UT of XT given X1,
which was X1
minus X0.
So, this thing
is super simple.
It is just
the thing that you want to learn
minus
X1 minus X0.
Super simple.
Okay. So, now why is it equivalent to
optimize on the flow matching and the
conditional flow matching loss?
That's another question.
So, if you remember for score matching,
we had a very similar question.
So, I'm going to give you the same
trick.
So, let's assume
you have distance squared of A minus B,
which is basically what we have here.
And what you want is to optimize these
losses with respect to the parameters of
the model theta.
So, everything that you care here
is only
terms that are function of theta.
So, A minus B, that norm squared is
equal to
a squared minus two
dot product of a and b plus b squared.
So, u t theta x squared
this and this are the same.
Perfect.
So, how about this term?
The b term is actually not
dependent on theta.
So, we actually don't care.
So, a a is good, is the same.
b
is not a function of theta. We we don't
care.
The only thing that is different between
these two
is the dot product of a
and b. So, this one and this one and
this one and this one.
So, what we want to show is the
expectation over t and x of these dot
products
is the same as the expectation over
these so t x1 and x over the conditional
probability path of this one and this
one. We want to show that these two are
the same.
So,
I'm going to do this
in 2 minutes.
So,
Okay.
So, let's suppose
So, we're going to go from one side and
end up with another. So, what I'm going
to do is start from the dot product of
the conditional flow matching loss
and end up with the one from the flow
matching one.
So, what I'm going to compute is
the expectation and here I'm going to
say t x1
and x
of
the dot product
of u t theta of x
and
your conditional vector field. So,
u t of x
given x1.
So, what I'm telling you is by
definition of the expectation
So, this is just a bunch of integrals.
So, this is the integral over t over x1
and x of u t
of
theta of x
dot product with the conditional vector
field u t of x given x1.
And this is over x1 and x. So, I'm going
to say it's p data
of x1 and then the conditional
probability path x given x1
uh dx1 dx dt.
So, far so good?
So, here what we notice
is
that if we put this quantity here
the this quantity here
and if I divide
by p t of x
and I do times p t of x
then what I'm going to recognize
is the marginal
vector field that we have constructed.
So, this is going to be equal
to the integral over t
integral So, this integral over x1 is
also going to come here.
So, integral over T, integral over X
of
U T
theta of
X
and this U T of X, which is the marginal
vector field
times
this probably marginal probability path
P T of X
D X D T
And this is nothing else
than the expectation over T
and X
which is drawn from the marginal
probability path
of
the dot product of U T theta of X
and the marginal vector field.
Which is exactly what we want.
So, what I'm showing you here is
that the marginal vector field, the way
we constructed it
allows us to optimize on a loss, the
conditional flow matching loss, which is
much more tractable
and leads us to the same gradients
with respect to theta.
And so, long story short
we have this loss, which is called the
conditional flow matching loss
which is the expectation over T X1,
which is drawn over the P data, and then
X drawn over the conditional probability
path
of a quantity that is extremely simple.
So, it's just the squared distance
between
the learned velocity, which is what you
want to learn
and
the conditional vector field
which we saw was nothing else than just
X1 minus X0.
So, it's a very tractable loss
and it does exactly what you want.
Any questions? So, it's a lot.
Are you all clear with this?
Okay, I'm going to say
that's it's okay if you feel like it's a
lot. It is indeed a lot. So, I'm going
to recap the strategy.
So, what we said
at the very beginning
was that we had two different views
of how we want to go from
one distribution to another
distribution.
What we said was that there was this
quantity called the vector field, aka
the velocity
that was linked to how we could move our
particles, so with the OD DX over DT
equal vector field.
That one.
But also the continuity equation
that linked the vector field with the
probability path.
So, what we want is to find
the vector field that will allow us to
go from P0 to P1.
So, what you need to do is to find
first a probability path that goes from
P1 to start to from P0 to P1.
First, you need to find that.
And then you need to construct
a vector field
that indeed allows you to go from P0 to
P1.
So, how do you do How do you do that?
Well,
you propose some quantities
and you try to see if the continuity
equation is indeed satisfied.
So, that's step number one.
Once you know your
vector field of interest,
your goal now is to learn it.
Because if you learn it,
then what you can do is to integrate the
OD.
Why do you want to integrate the OD?
It's because you want to go from X0 to
X1.
Therefore, you need to learn your vector
field.
And here what we did
is in order to learn the vector field,
we first
thought of a very simple case of us
wanting to go from the initial to a
single point
via the conditional probability path and
the conditional vector field.
So, this is the simple case with the
Dirac distribution
being the target distribution.
And then what we said was, "Okay, given
this very simple case that is super
tractable,
let's try to match our initial
distribution with the actual
target one of interest, which is the
whole data distribution, not just a
single point, but the whole data
distribution."
And
we proposed the marginal probability
path,
which uh satisfied
T equal 0 equal P0, and T equal 1, it's
equal to P data. So, it was it was a
valid probability path.
And we also saw that the constructed
vector field
was actually generating
that proposed marginal probability path.
It was generating it. Why?
Because it satisfied the continuity
equation.
Which I said I I have time to derive,
but you just need to
replace the quantities
and see that the continuation continuity
equation is indeed satisfied.
So, given that
we were finally with the vector field
that was
something that was adapted to our use
case.
But now what we wanted to do was to
learn it with a tractable loss.
So, in this last part
what we did is
show that
the loss that we wanted to optimize
was actually equivalent to another loss
that was extremely tractable, which is
the conditional flow matching loss.
And the way we showed that
was by showing that the gradient of
these losses with respect to theta were
equal
which is what I did here.
And then finally we have our final loss
function, which is UT theta of X minus
X1 minus X0.
Expectation of that.
So, it's incredibly simple.
So,
everything I told you
is actually So, a lot of it is coming
from this paper that's called flow
matching for generative modeling.
So, I highly recommend reading it.
It's may not be the simplest to read,
but I hope
what I just told you actually
will allow you to understand the
formulas in there a bit better.
But I didn't want to
give it to Sherwin before telling you a
bit more about why we're calling this
whole thing flow matching.
Cuz score matching
just called score matching because you
try to match the score.
But here
we're not matching the flow, we're
matching the velocity. So, one natural
question
is why is it not called velocity
matching? Why is it not called vector
field matching? Why is it called flow
matching?
So, these points are a bit more
informal. It's just uh personal take on
why that is the case.
So, one potential reason is historically
these models, which are flow models,
meaning trying to map a point to another
via this site of X0,
they had the term flow in their names.
And in particular,
the method that I mentioned that tried
to learn
the vector field with maximum likelihood
estimation, that one was called
continuous normalizing flows.
So, one reason is maybe
branding.
But actually,
I want to get back to my earlier
Lipschitz continuity comment.
It turns out
that if the vector field that you learn
here
is Lipschitz continuous,
then what happens is that your
trajectories, they're all unique.
So, you actually have a mapping between
vector fields that you learn
and the flow.
So, if you're matching the velocity,
you're also matching the flow.
Now, you may be wondering, okay, why how
do I know that the learned vector field
is indeed
Lipschitz continuous?
Well, we have not seen that yet. We're
going to see that in lecture five.
But
the model that is behind this learned
vector field
is something that is composed of matrix
multiplications and some smooth
activation functions.
All of that is
Lipschitz continuous.
So, what you will learn is actually a
Lipschitz continuous
vector field with respect to X.
Which is going to give you
a one-to-one mapping between velocity
and flow.
And we have
2 minutes. So, bear with me.
In 2 minutes, I'm going to cover how we
train and do inference.
But, it's going to be very easy.
So, let's see how we do training.
So, as I mentioned,
the loss is extremely simple.
And so, what we do is we sample the
noise, so X0 from your standard Gaussian
distribution.
Your clean image, so X1 from your
training set, which is P data.
And you also sample your time step.
And what you do is you construct XT.
Your noise image.
And what I'm telling you is thanks to
the loss function that we derived, what
we do is we use XT,
the noise image, and T
to predict
X1 - X0, which is the conditional vector
field,
via this
model that is your vector field model.
And you're going to compute the loss and
back propagate.
That's how you do training. Now, how do
you do inference? Well,
inference, you just sample from an easy
data distribution, and here it's again
standard normal distribution.
And what you're going do
is to numerically solve the ODE.
So, what you do is you go time time step
by time step, and you use your learned
vector field,
and you end up with your final estimated
image X1.
And that's how you do inference.
And with that, I'm going to give it to
Sherwin.
Thank you, Sherwin.
So, now we're going to see in a more
visual manner the training process and
discuss some edge cases and how to solve
them in practice.
So, you remember the training process
that Ashvin just mentioned.
You sample X0 from the normal
distribution. You sample X1 from your
training set.
And what you do is that you draw a
straight line between the two,
and you try to fit the velocity to this
X1 minus X0.
Now, I want you to imagine
that we do that for a given pair,
and now for another pair.
And suppose that these pairings
intersect
at a given point.
And let's suppose that this intersection
is for a same T.
So, in other words, we're trying to fit
the loss
at a same X at a same T
on two different vectors.
So, who knows
what the resulting learned velocity will
be?
So, it cannot be two velocities, right?
We cannot have a two vectors at a single
point. It has to be
one.
So, we have this MSE loss
that will make it such that it will be
an average of all all vectors that we
try to fit at the given points
X and at given point T.
And
you see that
as being a problem or
So, what does that mean?
So, here in practice, let's say you're
at inference time
and you want to go from, let's say, X0
to X1.
And let's say you have learned a vector
field
of velocity that doesn't go to X1, that
goes
in an average direction.
Are you going to be
able to go to X1?
No, right?
So, the thing that will occur is that
you're going to have something averaged
that might repel
the trajectories that you try to learn
into different directions.
And
but be reassured, we showed that these
learned vector fields were such that if
you sample a point
in the normal distribution and follow
the learned vector field, you land
into a distribution land
that will be your distribution P data.
So, that part is fine.
But still
you have these property that the learned
trajectories are not going to be the
same as the ones that you teach your
model.
And that is a source of what I would
call complexity where you teach a model
that doesn't
follow what you said at at test time.
So, that is inherently So, your
intuition
could make you feel that this is not
uh efficient.
And the second thing that I want to say
is that you could have this phenomenon
happening
even though
the uh points of intersection are not at
the exact same t because in practice
you're going to learn this vector field
with a neural network.
A neural network
are going to be a class of functions
that are going to be smoothing things in
space. So you won't have
drastic change of velocity for
neighboring t's.
And yeah, so because one
one thing that you could have told me is
but you're even that is never going to
happen.
0 1 is an interval with infinitely many
numbers. You're never going to draw the
same t and you would be right. And I'm
just saying that it could be valid for
neighboring t's.
So
and more importantly
let's say you sample your points x0 out
of your normal distribution.
What is going to be your issue here?
I've seen mentioned that you want to
integrate the ODE at inference time.
And we had seen last time that you want
to find methods that optimize that
number of NFE's
in such a way that you can find your
target sample in a minimum amount of
steps.
And
when you have a path that is getting
curved so you don't have these straight
lines at inference time
you're not going to be able to solve
that in a single step because that's the
way you use Euler. Euler is estimating
the velocity at the beginning points.
And if you try to do it in a single
step, it will end up somewhere else. It
will follow a straight path whereas the
curve isn't going to be taken into
account.
Um
and I know you're going to tell me but
you're even you have tricks in your
pockets. Last time you talked about
DPM solver in a different setting that
was able to reframe things in an exact
way. Well, no.
This time the ODE that we want to
integrate
has no linear components. It's all
non-linear because here we're directly
learning that velocity field.
So, no DPM solver here. Uh you need to
use traditional um sampler techniques.
Um okay. So, not quite not quite happy.
We're happy, but not quite.
Uh so, now I'm going to walk you through
the intuition of
a retraining or fine-tuning procedure
um that is called Reflow.
And um so, first I'm going to recap the
training procedure that we have already.
So, you sample a point x0, you sample a
point x1, you draw a path, and then you
uh fit a velocity on it. So, it is
called in that paper a one rectified
flow model.
And you obtain
trajectories that we we saw were going
to be curved.
And
one idea that we have here, one
temptation,
is to locate these new pairings. So, you
started from point x0, you integrated
the ODE, you ended up at somewhere in
the distribution of p data. You're
tempted to use these new pairs
as your new pairings
because they will be
by construction in such a way that the
the velocity field will carry the
trajectory directly there, right?
So, the Reflow procedure says, "Okay,
let's take these new pairs as those that
we used to retrain
the model."
So, these will be our our new um lines
that we fit our new model.
And
uh so, this is the re-flow step.
And you do that process again and again
until your lines becomes straighter.
And once that is the case, at inference
time, you're able to use a limited
amount of inference steps in order to
get your sample
um in in the P data space.
So does this procedure make sense? Yep.
So the comment is if you retrain, then
uh the two points are going to be from
the new distribution. So the magic in
all of this
So first, you're going to keep that
Gaussian distribution at the beginning.
That will not change.
And at the end, we're going to see that
there are some properties that makes it
such that the resulting points that you
get still preserve the distribution P
data.
So there there is some theoretical
justification that that it does follow P
data.
But um this is a great point. We're
going to discuss that in more detail in
two slides.
Any other questions or comments?
Okay, so you're right to be skeptical.
So this works because of two things. So
first
uh so actually one slide.
Uh so we need to show that this follows
the distribution P data.
So I'm not going to give you the whole
proof, just the gist of it. So you start
by defining this random variable that
starts at at X0, and you integrate the
ODE to end up in the new space,
and
define this uh velocity um for the X
random variable
and the the proof to show that the law
that you get
for the end distribution after a re-flow
procedure goes through showing
that these two
probability flows
respect the same continuity equation.
And with some uh, uniqueness theorem and
the presence of uh, initial conditions
at the fact that PT like equals zero
is still the Gaussian distribution.
You can show that it's valid for for all
T and in particular T equals 1.
So, yeah. Just hand-waving
the proof here. So, it's
theoretically the case.
But, you are right to be skeptical
because once you integrate the ODE
you have errors that that come in from
two sources. So, the first error is
discretization error. So, as we said
we're sampling these new points. So,
maybe you have some errors in the way
you do these steps. So, you don't
necessarily end up in the theoretical
um, location you should be at.
And the second point is that you're
operating off of a learned vector field
that is approximated by a neural
network.
And it it is possible that you haven't
learned it perfectly. I mean, of course,
it's sure that you haven't learned it
perfectly.
Um, and the
quality of your results will be a
function of how well you learn that
vector field
and of your discretization errors. And
we're going to see very soon that this
is one of the reasons why we don't
perform this re-flow procedure too many
times
because the degradation is going to be
um,
a trade-off to to balance here.
Okay, so this is the first point I
wanted to justify. The second point I
wanted to justify is we hand-waved the
fact that the flows, like the
trajectories, were getting straighter.
And there is a mathematical way of
writing it down and proving it, and this
is also something that is being proven,
in case you're interested.
And for the interest of time, I'm not
going to be covering it, but that S
um
quantity quantifies straightness
and compares
the actual velocity with the theoretical
one, and we show that it decays with
a a good speed, and this is why we're
saying it it's getting a straighter.
And exactly as we discussed, the reflow
procedure is one that you wouldn't want
to do too many times,
uh but usually one procedure is already
great.
And the goal is for us to use uh very
simple sampling techniques, such as
Euler, um optimally in just a few steps
finding the the right solution.
And of course, it it isn't a free lunch,
it it comes at a trade-off, so
you're trading off
simplicity
and potentially lower quality for faster
inference time speeds.
Okay, great.
So, these past three lectures, including
this one,
we've come across these concepts of
diffusion, score matching, and now
flows, flow matching.
And I want to spend 5 minutes together
to tie all of these frameworks together
in a way
that will hopefully show links between
them and the fact that we are solving
the same category of problems, but we
from different lenses.
And in order to do that, I'm going to
look at each of the processes that we
defined
and then look at the difference with
respect to each method.
So, the first one
is the forward process. So, it's a long
time ago already, 2 weeks ago we talked
about DDPM and all this class of
discrete time diffusion
um
and then we saw in score-based diffusion
world that if you reframed these
equations
uh and converted it into uh like
continuous time
put some delta T to zero, you could get
some SDE formulation that was equivalent
to it.
Uh where we saw at the DPM solver
section that actually in diffusion space
you could approximate I mean, you could
always assume that f of x and t was
linear in x.
And this is why So, it's something that
we haven't seen so far, but I'm telling
you that you have a nice closed-form
expression with respect to f and g of
xt.
And now we saw today
that you can write down xt
uh as an interpolation between x0 and x1
in flow matching.
And now we're going to see that in all
of these
methods
you start from a clean sample. So, in a
diffusion space, we start
uh the clean sample from t equals zero.
But, in flow matching space, we saw that
the notation was reversed. Uh clean
sample is t equals one.
And on the other side of the spectrum,
you have noise
uh which was in a diffusion world at
equals big T and here is t equals zero.
So, you're here
uh
drawing an an
between the two in each of these cases.
Uh now, when we look at the last
functions, we saw that the diffusion
uh view of writing things down was
focusing on noise.
Uh the score-based
uh the score matching view was
uh linking scores, and you had a nice
relationship between noise and score.
And in the flow matching world, you were
directly fitting the velocity field such
that you have the simplest ODE to
integrate in the end.
Now, when we look at the generation
process, we saw in the diffusion world
that you had all these steps
uh to go through with some
stochasticity,
which you also had in the score-based
diffusion world.
And you had for the first two
a deterministic counterpart. And you
will notice that the flow matching one
doesn't have such a balance because it's
deterministic to start with.
And I'm just showing you
some relationships between all these
methods, but actually there is a whole
theory linking these concepts in a very
nice way.
And this is why I recommend, if you're
interested, so it's out of scope for
this class and it just if you're
interested,
uh to take a look at the paper called
stochastic interpolants
that writes down equations that links
all of these together and turns out that
out of noise,
score, and velocity, if you know two of
them, you can deduce the third one.
And that paper
designs a problem space that is bigger
than what each of these frameworks
detailed. And um and and all of these
frameworks can live in a in the same
unified framework.
And with that,
I hope you have a great weekend.